So we have leaked audio of the horrible Texas
Republican Governor Greg Abbott admitting
something obvious, which is that reopening
the economy of Texas is going to spread the
Corona virus.
This is no big surprise.
It's no great realization, but it's important
because it is not that Greg Abbott doesn't
believe reopening will spread the virus.
It's that he's decided reopening makes sense,
even though it will spread the virus.
And The Daily Beast got a hold of this audio,
which is from right after Greg Abbott letting
the Texas stay at home order expire.
This was on a call with Texas legislators.
And he says what we all know, how do we know
real result spread more cases of the matter
is pretty much every scientific and medical
report shows that whenever you have a real
opening up in morning, it's amazing because
behind closed doors, sometimes they actually
sound like rational people.
If you just isolated that audio of saying,
here's what the medical experts are saying,
it will increase the spread period.
They don't sound that different than the responsible
governors that we've seen manage these crises,
some of which are Democrats and some of which
are Republicans.
It's refreshing in a sense, but of course,
he's still reopening the state and the numbers
aren't looking so good.
And it only proves that what he's doing is
not out of ignorance.
It's actually out of indifference.
And the media went right after Abbott for
comment.
After this audio leaked, his spokesperson,
John Whitman, said, oh, no, no, no, this is
no big deal.
All the governor is saying here is that medical
experts claim that there could be more cases,
but we're doing more testing.
So everything is completely fine.
That is the epitome of what you call crisis
management and spin.
Now, another response has been.
Life has risk.
This is not just Texas now, but we've heard
this from a lot.
We've heard it from our favorite right wing
ideological commentators and from governors
and all.
All over the place.
Life has risk.
If you want to really be safe, you've got
to stay in your house all the time, forever.
And even in your house, you could end up dying
of carbon monoxide poisoning if you leave
your gas stove on or whatever.
I mean, it's it's really quite cynical.
And of course, in a literal sense, any action,
including merely leaving your house, increases
your risk to some degree of catching a communicable
disease.
And again, even in your house, there is not
a zero level risk of catching a communicable
disease or of getting hurt in some other way.
But this is not some vague thing.
This is a really specific decision right now
about re-opening when we know we have a communicable
disease spreading for which we have no vaccine
and only are starting to figure out some treatments
that have some effect.
But they don't care.
They've decided that and this is important.
They've decided that the facade of the economy
is what matters.
I'm not even going to say the economy, because
what they really care about is the facade
of the economy, which we experience through
the
stock market.
The sort of political perspective on whether
Trump has done a good job justifying his reelection.
The facade is what they care about.
And many states have decided that that is
what they care about.
Friday, Greg Abbott is allowing tanning salons,
hair salons, barbershops to reopen, getting
people off of unemployment.
Also seems to be a big impetus for pushing
this, and that is driving a lot of states
to decide to reopen more and more of the economy
or at least to allow more and more of the
economy to reopen.
And anytime you're talking about Greg Abbott,
you also have to wonder about the role of
oil, oil and gas prices.
Gasoline I'm talking about have collapsed
because there's no demand.
Airplanes aren't flying.
People aren't driving much.
Opening states will get people at least driving.
That will increase demand for oil and gasoline.
And
there's always, you know, a dozen angles on
this and all of them are ugly.
Now, how are the numbers looking in Texas?
Not too good.
Texas going from roughly four to five hundred
new cases a day in mid-April.
Now they are regularly in the range of eight
hundred to twelve hundred new cases.
Understand that the federal narrative.
By that I mean Trump.
The narrative has been.
We're past the peak.
We are well past the peak since April 12th
or so.
He's been talking about being past the peak.
Texas is new cases per day have doubled in
the last 15.
Days.
What the Trump administration is pretending
is going on is make believe it is only pretend
the opposite is happening and happening in
many states.
The death numbers, of course, lagging cases
to some degree, but those also starting to
climb in Texas since the
last days of April.
Many states clearly not on the downswing.
And Texas appears to be one of those